today is the first annual corridor
cook-off everyone is out trying to
figure out what they're going to make
for judge Nico and how they're going to
present it GrubHub has agreed to sponsor
this video and as a result the winner of
this great cook-off will be getting to
order GrubHub for an entire week that's
right at home at night during the day
for lunch at the studio no matter the
price point for a week on the house what
the guys don't know I'm just going to
order GrubHub myself and present it to
Nico and it's easily going to be the
best meal which means that I only have
to make one order and I get to eat free
for life for a week rustic very dish
competition cooking it with them drum
just fried up some sourness a little bit
get that warmth
maybe a little crisp on the outside a
simple Italian sandwich really I like to
keep it pretty straightforward and we
can a turkey sandwich do it's going to
be delish and it's a old SF recipe
learned it at a Chinese restaurant so
I'm not really much of a cook so by
alright what is the most efficient thing
that I can cook in a certain amount of
time chicken noodle soup I'm ordering
right now
nickels think is a pretty classy guy I'm
gonna get him a fish dish I'm gonna get
him a little dessert side little
baguette something French she seems like
you know he's kind of got a little bit
about it going on so you know I don't
want I don't want it to be too fancy
because then people might get suspicious
do you think they're here you're judging
today's Cordura cooking competition with
an attorney remain impartial he's going
to withhold from saying anything inside
tasty
guys judge Spiegel here so get ready
hill amigo
many Christians what I prepared for you
is a hot italian dhimmis with pastrami
hands peppers and cheap presentations
nice cheese perfectly melted
Tayla taste it's not bad as I questioned
the thickness of your salami slices they
kind of make it hard to bite through so
this is a home meal chicken noodle soup
it's great
honesty's camp dominated by noodles it's
my carrot noodle soup and chicken noodle
to mean room temp so I have all these
all these little ground meats I went
over around the streets to gather enough
together I put my little dustpan and I
just press them together just for you
caramelized onions I know you like
hamburgers and I know you love all those
little meats that hanging around I can
simply pick them all up put them in one
place for you enjoy all right the size
of avocado look enticing we press the
ledge not overly hanging out the side
but it's all coming out one side to
never do is capture old malfunction yeah
might I recommend a toothpick through
the center next time right you're right
Bob you take a look at certain
sandwiches American classic cold it's
hard dead it tastes like high school I
like the simplicity you want my colors a
rustic turkey sandwich the peghead used
in toasting maybe a little more their
butter must have made a sense of a
condiment turkey day season but a little
bit full ego this beautiful meal I call
gibraltar okay because it stands above
the rest
hence the biggest side next to yesterday
caught Pacific fish right there
okay but yesterday today today's catch I
wouldn't leave you hanging with just a
simple entree you're going to finish it
off with a little slice New York
cheesecake a little imposing perhaps but
I appreciate the creativity
[Music]
so the fish is light and flaking
well-seasoned like to cleanse my palate
after meal so no little sleep in the
graham cracker crust press cheese - top
L okay I think I made my decision
Jake Watson with what we called the
monument yes Gibraltar developer yeah
thank you so much I haven't eaten yet so
I'm gonna go order some lunch first
thing Thai I love Thai food I'm actually
into the the curries let me go for the
chicken curry dinnertime tacos I've been
ending up grub up for about four days
now and I've been eating so much good
food that I'm kind of even getting sick
of food at this point like I I know
that's awful to say but I've literally
been eating at every restaurant I've
wanted to eat at from around town yeah
you just kind of been back here just
chilling it is like um fun oh so funny
thing actually um so it's just taking a
look pretty kind some things that goes
up on the day we're we're cooking all
that sweet pretty girls then yeah what I
want all this awesome food yeah I don't
know what I noticed those that actually
own thing and it says actually in that
morning before we even do this there was
an order for a fish roe fish place and
it's really funny because that's what
you gave me go which is fish so I'm just
I'm starting to think when two and two
together your
thinking you're cheatin for brief moment
I actually thought you were an
incredible chef and now I'm starting to
realize thanks if you take this whole
thing I just the food just I just
thought of food it blinded me man I'm
just I think I think it'd just be best
if he just took off for a little mini
stick to us today off here and just uh
let us all come to have a little tent
alone without you here
[Music]
you
something so gizmo duck effect then you
learn anything cool that's worth sharing
yeah I was just a lot of practice in
particular which is a piece of software
for After Effects yeah just like you
either
how you doing man are you in a wolf suit
I threw it all away for a couple of hot
lunches don't you remember pretend out
the crumpled thing I was like three days
ago al anybody remembers that what
really
well I messed up it's probably gonna
take me a while to regain the trust of
the rest of the guys but thank God for
Peter you know I didn't really notice
him before he's a great guy I'm going to
start paying more attention to him and
asking him how he's doing and making
sure that he feels that he's a part of
this you know because without him I
wouldn't be back here making youtube
videos I'll tell you that much
yeah what's the truth Oh didn't see you
there you got me in a moment of
self-reflection thinking about how I can
treat my co-workers a little bit better
also thanks to GrubHub for sponsoring
this video did you know that they're the
largest food delivery service in the
nation with over 50,000 restaurant
options in 1,100 cities you can get the
food that you're craving whenever you
want wherever you are also you can get
seven dollars off your first order I
going to go link in the description no
free trials just go there just seven
bucks off a meal thank me later
[Music]